hello everybody this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is my 120 and today what I want
to start with is Christmas decorations
you're seeing them everywhere they're
getting bigger and crazier every day and
everybody's asking and wondering do you
like them do you hate them and I'm gonna
tell you very simply I am in love with
the massive Christmas lights and
celebrations and decorations I'm gonna
tell you why
circa 1985 my mom driving around town my
sister and I had the greatest game ever
made we would pick out and yell out the
window if we saw lights and decorations
we would keep count I won a lot but I
loved that a great throwback moment to
me I love Christmas decorations now
let's talk about stuff on and in the
news something I really want to talk
about is a website called divorced 360 a
new site to talk you through how to get
divorced websites are getting
interesting number26 apart cells live
journal - a Russian company a lot of
people freaking out listen I come from
Russia I know where you're coming from
however I think that will be okay I
think box was too close to live journal
and was a necessity and a necessary move
for six apart so I'm saying kudos to
that good stuff also another thing
college football sucks it's pissing me
off the BCS makes no sense whatsoever
computers analyzing games I mean why
don't we just watch video games being
played I mean makes no sense to me
whatsoever
I mean Missouri beats Kansas in here's
us two weeks ago and they don't get into
the BCS no no excuse dig the biggest
site on the Internet's in a lot of
people's opinion you know just a very
popular site finally releases photos
today
so you can finally dig your favorite
photos should be a great great feature
and finally Yahoo
announces its top searches of the year
Britney Spears number one
WWF number two Paris Hilton number three
Fergie number nine Lindsay Lohan number
six what does this tell me tells me that
Perez Hilton should have the most
visited website in the universe see you
next time on my 120